tom from sky please
what is the public health justification
for ending the requirement to self uh to
self isolate if inspected and if the
government does bring that forward is it
prepared to do so against the guidance
of the who during a global pandemic
and given the suggestion that today's
announcements have only been made given
the political difficulty the prime
minister finds himself in do you as
health secretary offer him your
unqualified support or are you like
rishi sunak going to reserve judgment
ahead of the great report and can you
hand on heart say that you've never
spent the rules
okay well
let me start and
on that i mean first you asked about the
self-isolation rules ending the
self-isolation rules if you're positive
of course that is uh still a requirement
uh that it is something that as i've
said a moment ago the prime minister's
referred to today we will review so
there's no decision on that at this
point but it is clear that despite the
the changes that we're announcing today
there is still a very high rate of
prevalence some i think around 1 in 20
according to the latest ons
data and it is important currently to to
keep those rules in place we will of
course review them uh i don't want to
presume the outcome of that review but
it is reasonable to think just as
we're living with flu for example we
don't require people to legally
self-isolate but to remain cautious to
be sensible if they're infected we will
eventually have to find a way to live
with covid in a similar fashion
on your question about the the prime
minister i i fully support the prime
minister and and as i said a moment ago
it's it's important to me and to the
country that he's come to the house he's
apologized and uh i think it's right
that we're waiting for the outcome of of
the report and when that is complete
this investigation establishes the facts
that the prime minister will come back
and answer further questions and i think
you asked me about
me and rules whether i have observed the
rules if i heard you correctly and you
know i i can say i've i with full
confidence i've absolutely observed the
covert 19 rules at all times
and
i would say
you like millions
of people across the country
it hasn't been easy
you're like like millions i my mom lives
alone i couldn't go and see her
i couldn't go to a close friend's
funeral
and it wasn't easy
but it was the right thing to do as as
millions have done up and down the
country when they were asked to and
it's it's important also that that if we
look at today's announcement that you
know because millions and millions have
observed the rules they've done the
right thing that we can take the
measures that we're taking today and
remove these restrictions on our
freedoms which should always be a last
resort so i'm proud of the british
people and what they've allowed us to
achieve in our fight against this horrid
virus